hello Karen warning with Funkers radio
show we are outside the studio with
miles maker we just had an incredible
interview it went much too fast one of
the questions that we didn't get to that
we wanted to talk about is the idea that
you know a lot of us go into this
business not merely just to be famous or
to make a million dollars but just to
have a sustainable living and feel good
about what we do and maybe work at
something that makes us just feel
fulfilled miles what do you think is the
reality for someone that wants to be
just the middle class artist do you
think it's attainable someone who is
able to sustain themselves through
selling their dvds off their website
whatever it is but you know not not on
the level of some of the a-list
celebrity stars but maybe just a
lesser-known name that's able to just
make money and not have to work a day
job doing what they love you think
that's attainable um it definitely is
you know and people are doing it now
quietly you know and the fact that we
don't know everybody that's doing it is
a testament to the idea that you can
just quietly find your space and your
way of doing business and your way of
sharing your art and sustaining yourself
I think the big thing is you know this
whole dimple middle class thing is you
know what is middle class what is it an
acceptable amount of money that that you
know you're going to be happy with to
call yourself you know a sustainable
artist and I think that's really the key
but I also think it might depend where
you live like you know just being here
in LA for the short period of time this
week I found that
it cost of living is a lot lower here
which really surprised me I wasn't
expecting that and New York is a very
expensive place to live so I think that
that bears a little bit into it and also
how savvy a person is there are some
artists that are not as savvy
technologically they're not you know
using a lot of computer social media
type on platforms and therefore their
ability to generate revenue is probably
you know it's severely reduced versus
somebody who's you know more tech savvy
and on a computer and understanding how
to reach people that they cannot
physically touch you know enter in time
zones and parts of the world that can
still be a customer without you know
ever engaging directly with you know the
artist but I just think it's a beautiful
thing that um some of these platforms
that I call you know mega platforms that
are actually still very accessible to
filmmakers like you know Netflix or
Amazon you know amazon has reached out
to canada now they're going to be
overseas i believe in europe so as their
reach expands and our accessibility to
get our content on those platforms still
remains then our ability to sell to
other markets now will begin to grow and
I just think it's a matter of
understanding or just having a strategy
man and we talk about this all the time
it's like everyone's banging their head
against the wall about strategy but
sometimes you just have to just jump out
and do stuff and just what's working
keep doing that and what's not working
pull it back you know I think some of
the best companies do that Apple you
know they just okay we tried that it
didn't work we're gonna pull it back
we're not afraid you know now we're
going to try this over here you know but
there but they're willing to jump in you
know and we've got to be able only to
jump in
Oh